يا ريت الواقع سهل مثل الحكي
بيكبر بضله محافظ على هالبراءه هاي هي
الفطره اللي الله خلقنا عليها
حلم محمود هو انه يصير بيانيست
هل الكلام هو الوسيله الوحيده للتعبير عن
الافكار والمشاعر قالها ابو الفلسفه
الحديثه ديكارت انا افكر اذا انا موجود لم
يقل انا اتكلم اذا انا موجود كم وسيله
للتواصل نجد حولنا الرسم لغه والموسيقى
لغه والغناء والكتابه والرياضه الاخرى
وحتى للعيون لغه كل منا مختلف نتقاسم
الكثير ونختلف في الكثير ايضا كذلك اصحاب
التوحد متشابهون ومختلفون فالاختلاف هو
التنوع والتنوع هو الحياه
منذ ان اكتشف الطب التوحد قبل ثمانيه عقود
ما زال نصفه من حولنا يره لغزا ونصف ذلك
النصف لا يحاول ان يعرف اي شيء عن التوحد
حتى العلم اختلف بشانه البعض يراه اضطرابا
نفسيا او عصبيا والبعض الاخر يراه اشكالا
جنيا بيولوجيا لماذا لا نعرف الكثير عن
التوحد
اليوم نحاول الوصول اليهم لن نبحث عن سبب
ولا عن طبيب ولا عن علاج انها مهمه خاصه
نذهب فيها اليهم لنعرف بماذا يفكرون وماذا
يشعرون هل يعيشون اللحظه فقط ام لديهم
احلام وامنيات هل يعرفون المراهقه ما هو
الكذب او المجامله بالنسبه اليهم هل
يعرفون انهم مختلفون